Hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 11 of my GE only challenge. Uh
last episode we did manage to unlock the
sewer system uh which has been so much
better. Training on mos shines is
infinitely better than on guards. Uh for
this episode I really want to focus on
flipping and doing anything that will
make me money. Uh because I've noticed I
would like to dump money into my skills
like construction or prayer or um
crafting, but I just don't have enough
money to sustain the investment. I'd
rather start building up a sizable cash
stack and I can start just easily losing
five or six million to a skill and it's
not a big deal. Whereas now that's
cutting like my entire cash stack off.
So, um I'm definitely going to focus on
that. One other thing I want to do is
possibly upgrade my house. I won't be
able to get a gilded altar anytime soon,
but I can get a welfare alter, I'm
pretty sure. And then I can kind of
train some prayer and not feel so bad
about it. Um, and yeah, so I hope you
guys enjoyed the episode. Thanks for
sticking around and let's get started.
Okay, so starting off the episode, I
have some flips coming in that I think I
put in at the end of the last one. Uh,
the monk's robe and the Infinity Gloves.
Uh, pretty good margins on those. We
went from 1559 to 1678, which is like
11520.
and the monk's robe. Uh, got actually a
400k margin on that. That is insane. Uh,
next up, I'm going to put an offer in
for some Zamrack godsword ornament kits.
Uh, ornament kits have worked pretty
well in the past. And I'm going to do
the hood of darkness as well. Okay, so
we have another farming level coming in.
That's going to be level 36 farming.
Now, grow well bushes, which we're never
going to do. I'm still kind of
considering uh spending some money to
just get my farming to 42 so I can start
planting uh better trees. But for now,
I'll probably just keep uh planting the
willows because it's pretty cost
effective and we'll get there
eventually. Okay, so ended up just
ditching the ornament kit cuz it was not
coming through and flipped it to the uh
obsidian item which is on screen and the
infinity uh boots once again or infinity
glove, sorry. Uh the gloves give us
actually 400 uh can profit and the uh
obsidian item only about 100 10 a bit.
Okay, so another thing I want to try is
the Barrow's Repair. Once again, I'm
going to try putting in the Gthan's
chain skirt and the Gthan's helm
overnight, and hopefully I will actually
purchase a more substantial amount of
these cuz it's a very good margin for
repairing them right now. Uh, so I only
ended up buying the Gthan's helm, but I
ended up selling them for a 100k profit,
and that's after uh the cost of
repairing, maybe a little bit more, even
actually 115k. Uh, so pretty good and a
pretty safe method. Uh, but it's pretty
slow to buy the uh pieces because not
that many people are selling them. Okay,
and last up, I'm going to put in an
offer for the super energies. Uh, so I
can decant them as well as these samurai
gloves just because they are good flips
and have to do something for the day.
Okay, and we have another farming level
coming in. That is going to be level 38
farming. Uh, it's about four levels away
until I can plant the uh, maple tree.
Another thing worth noting is once I
unlock the maple tree, I'll be able to
do another money-making technique that
involves uh, turning seeds into
saplings. Uh, which will actually be
kind of nice to try. Okay, so we decided
to put another flip in for the black
deeyed chaps. We're going to put in for
three of those, as well as three of the
mummy's legs, which are just a slow
item, but should have a good margin. Uh,
the super energies ended up doing a
pretty decent flip. Uh,
150k roughly. Okay, so we actually got a
book of knowledge here at the good old
moss giants. We're going to be tossing
that into thieving. Once again, we're
getting pretty close to a thieving
level. What do you guys think? Do you
think it's worth it to just go for a
random skill like this? Or should I be
putting it in something like agility or
something that might actually make a
difference at this level? All right,
there we go. There's level 49 agility or
I wish 49 health uh just at the moss
giants. We're going to get our range to
50 because they're really easy to range
here and you can safe spot them pretty
easily. Okay, so we actually hit level
50 range. Uh my internet is lagging
pretty badly. Uh luckily since then I
went ahead and bought a 100 foot
Ethernet cable because I was getting so
pissed off. Uh, and the connection is
running much better now. Okay, we
actually got an excellent flip on the
mummy's legs at 240k on each one in
profit and three of those giving us 77k.
Uh, really good. Uh, the black dehydide
chaps only about 200k in profit. Okay,
so I put an offer in for two of the
armal godsword ornament kits for about
2.5 mil and some zamarak pages for about
400k each. We'll give these a try and
just kind of varying up with some new
items and we'll do some skilling maybe
while these uh come through. Okay, we
got another tree coming in. What's that
going to be? Any levels? There we go. 39
farming. Only three left to go. It's
taking about three trees per level now.
And I'm kind of considering maybe going
and buying some bagged uh oak trees or
something like that just to finish us
off cuz it's starting to slow down quite
a bit. Okay, so the Armadil uh Godsword
kit sold very quickly for a 250k profit.
uh only been about 10 or 20 minutes
since I recorded uh the last clip. So,
I'll put another one in because uh it
was working so well. These arak pages
coming through pretty slowly, but uh
they're really cheap for what they're
at. So, I think it'll be worth it. Now,
like I said earlier, if I get my
construction level up a bit, I will be
able to have kind of a welfare alter
setup. And what I need to get it to is
59. And with a plus two boost, I'll be
able to make a uh I forget, like an oak
altar and some kind of well incense
scandals. But it'll give me about 250%
prayer experience over 100, which is so
much better. Uh, and I only need level
61, so it's actually not too bad. Okay,
well, I was training construction. I got
another genie lamp. And don't put it in
agility. I We're so close to a level. I
don't think we're going to get it,
though. It's only going to be 10
experience. I think we just need three
experience for it to even level. So, one
more lamp and I'll finally get a level
that is impossible to get otherwise.
Okay, so we're just training our
construction. We're continuing to do the
oak larders. I don't really think
there's a better option here. It's about
120k experience without a servant and
teleporting to the GE every time, which
is a little frustrating, but uh another
construction level coming in. That is
going to be level
59 construction. Uh there we go. Uh we
got that kind of all at once. It didn't
take too long. About 45 minutes. And now
I can use the plus two boost and uh
build my altar. Okay, so first up, we
have to build the chapel, which is going
to cost 50k coins. Uh we'll toss it here
just because I think we want it as close
as possible. And uh next I'll need to
upgrade my kitchen. Okay, so we're going
to give this a try. We uh put up all the
uh shelves and uh we built the stove in
the range that we need. Uh so to make
the PT, you just need to withdraw tea
leaves uh from your shelves or and your
larder and then um so you need the the
tea leaves from the larder and then you
get like a cup and uh the kettle from
the uh shelves and you just kind of boil
it on the range, put the tea leaves in,
pour into the cup, and now I have uh
some PT. So now if we drink it and have
a look at our construction level,
perfect. Goes up to 61. That'll allow us
to build both the incense burners and
the altar. Okay, so we built the first
incense burner. Uh that's going to be
the oak incense burner. And oh, it looks
like we only have to build one luckily.
And now we got the mahogany altar.
Perfect. There we go. And now we can
pray once they're lit for a 250%
uh boost to our prey level, which is
awesome. Okay, so I'm going to test out
my new altar. Uh so we have to actually
light it with Marentil, which doesn't
actually make much sense at all. Uh but
anyway, there we go. We just use the
bones on the altar and we're getting 180
prayer experience per go. That's
awesome. Uh still not as perfect as it
could be. We could be getting 100% extra
experience. Uh but still I'm happy with
that. Even this one inventory is going
to level up my prayer quite a bit. And
yeah, now we can actually invest some of
our money into prayer. I'm not really
sure if there's any particular prayer
that's going to be super useful. Uh but
it's a nice boost to our total level.
And it's just kind of nice to have an
alter of your own. Okay, this is just
the last of the We just bought like a
inventory of bones, but there is level
36 prayer. I'll probably come back and
maybe get it up to 45 or something. Uh,
we actually got a combat level as well.
Um, but yeah, pretty happy with how this
is working so far. Okay, so we sold off
the Armadel gods ornament kit for
another 250k in profit. The Zamar page
one, we got 70k in each one, uh, leading
to 140k profit there. So, not too bad.
And now we have 6.2 mil in profit. Uh, I
think we might invest a little bit of
this money into prayer. Okay, so I'm
going to buy 200 dragon bones. It's a
little pricey. It's about 600k. Uh,
we're kind of sinking into prayer and
not for any particular reason because I
don't see any prayers being terribly
useful uh for the GE only challenge, but
it's going to be some easy total levels
and I want to try out the alter more and
uh I don't know, I just kind of feel
like getting some easy total levels.
Okay, here we're back at our house. It's
really fun to do it actually in your own
place. Uh, something special about it.
And there's level 38 prayer. It's going
very quick. About a couple hundredk an
hour. Probably I think closer to 150.
But once we have the two uh upgraded
burners and the altar, it's going to be
a lot better. And here we go. We got
another prayer level coming through.
That's going to be uh 40 prayer very
quick. And just kind of a milestone. And
I think we might make it all the way to
44 45. Okay, we got another prayer level
coming in. And that's going to unlock
another protection prayer. That's going
to be protect from me. probably the most
important one arguably because I don't
think there's any ranged uh monsters
around here, but that's pretty nice.
Okay, and that's the last of our bones.
This is going to be the last level as
well. What did those tuner bones get us
to? Uh all the way to 45 prayer, which
is kind of a nice spot to stop at. I'm
pretty sure if I had the guild alter and
everything, it would have got an extra
couple three levels or so. Okay, so
before I went to bed, I put in an offer
for 8,000 adamant bolt and 8,000 diamond
bolt tips, uh which I have combined.
give me about 50k fletching experience,
which is not too bad. And uh I'm
probably gonna profit about 250k off of
that. On top of that, I have the hood of
darkness coming through, which we
flipped uh I think for about a 70k
profit. That being said, I only flipped
one of them and it cost me 70k to check
the margin. Uh so no profit there. Armal
dehide boots are profiting us a little
bit. So, one thing I want to finish off
that I've had here for a while is a
bunch of compost potions I've had in my
bank. It's about 500k in profit just
sitting here, but it's very slow and
tedious to do, but I think I'll go ahead
and combine them all now. Okay, we
finished all of them up and it was a
nice even 1,000. Uh, so we'll sell them
actually for about 538, which is very
good for the current prices. So, that's
538k there. Uh, we have the boots coming
in. Not a huge profit there. And uh
well, we'll check on uh got them for
$875, sold them for 915, so about 100k
profit there. And uh we got the diamond
bolts coming in. Uh which we'll just
quickly calculate cuz I didn't actually
get a chance to do that earlier. Uh so
it's 3.5 mil we sold all them for. And
we'll take what 1.7 off and then 1.56
leaving us with yeah 250k in profit. So
pretty nice. Okay, so I sold off all
these super compost. Uh, I probably
profited about 400k in that and it took
me about 30 minutes of actual time to
combine those all. On top of that, I
ended up buying two of the Obsidian Cape
Rs uh for I guess we bought them for
2600 and we sold them for 2844. So
that's 240k in profit on each cape and
we got two of those. So that's almost
500k there. And put definitely put
another offer in for another two of
those. Okay. And we're actually about to
hit a fletching level. We're getting
very close to 80 fletching. Only one
more level after this. Uh, it's
definitely slowing down, but the XP is
still really good and I'll be able to
move on to the magic shortbow pretty
soon. Uh, although that's not going to
profit us very much, so I'm not sure if
I'm going to do that indefinitely. Okay,
so we have another two obsidian capes
sold. That's another 500k in profit
roughly. And we sold off all of the
uncut bows. That leaves us at about 7.5
mil. Very nice. And I guess we'll put
another offer for another two of those.
Why not? All right, guys. That's going
to be about it. I'm just getting one
last farming level cuz I realized I had
some bag plants uh left in my bank. Uh
so we'll be able to get one more this
episode. Pretty close. Should just be
like one more.
And there we go. That's going to be
level 40 farming. I think that's a good
way to end the episode. Uh we only have
two more farming levels until we reach
our goal uh for farming. Now for other
things we got this episode, I got my
range to 50. Uh prayer all the way to
45, which is pretty awesome. Another big
one is the construction level all the
way to 59. Uh which has allowed us to uh
get a altar that actually is reasonably
good. Not amazing by any means. Uh on
top of that, we also got I guess a
fletching level. Uh now for our money,
we're looking at about 7.4 mil. I've
kind of liquidated all my stuff. None of
the flips are in right now. Uh but
easier to see this way. So 7.4 mil. Next
episode I should be able to hit 10 and
uh we'll just continue on from there. So
yeah, thanks for tuning in, guys, and
I'll see you guys in episode 12.
[Music]